[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements]
limousine
[Musique] [
Musique]
quelque chose n'était pas à moi ouais
[Musique] [
Musique] ça
sonne
bien
sûr
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tombe
dans tous les bons moments, j'ai eu
envie de
changement
et dans les mauvais moments, je me crains
[Musique] [
Musique]
nous sommes loin d'être superficiels maintenant [
va-t'en
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
oh
mon Dieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
étrangère
moi jusqu'où vas-
tu je
crois que toucher
[Musique]
étrangère [Musique
] [
Musique]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
tellement lui-même
merci